[Musique]
pour pour reprendre des crises
d'angoissé il faut se dire que ça arrive
à un moment de fragilité en général donc
ça peut être simplement parce qu'on est
malade fatigué un peu plus stressé que
d'habitude
à un moment on ressent le stress plus
grand que d'habitude simplement parce
qu'on est fragilisé le stress est
bizarre il est agressif il et on a du
mal à identifier donc ça me stresse qui
crée du stress
plus on lutte contre ce stress plus
l'augmenter c'est comme ça que se
déclenche les crises d'angoissé
malheureusement une fois qu'on a mis le
doigt dans ce cercle vicieux d'un sa
tendance à se remettre en place et à
continuer donc ce qu'il faut faire
absolument je crois que c'est un très
bon repère pour tous c'est faire de la
relaxation
on en trouve beaucoup on trouve sur la
chaîne youtube par exemple ou même sur
le livre que j'ai écrit sur le sommeil
le but de la relaxation ce que fait la
relaxation très concrètement c'est que
ça vous apprends à te calmes et s'éteint
c'est un apprentissage que vous allez
pouvoir regarder ça apprend à cannes de
deux manières ça développe le système
sympathique le fera un stress qui est
resté tel quel c'est que même quand vous
arrêterez la relation que vous resterez
calme et cela permet de s'habituer à son
stress
quel qu'il soit donc que ce soit
l'angoissent du corps à la virus ou bien
des crises d'angoissé mais est ce qu'il
faut en revanche et le faire en grande
quantité parce que si on fait en grande
quantité de l'hypnose de la méditation
la relaxation de la respiration les
méthodes jacob seul le training ce chêne
de schultz ont peu importe plein plein
de choses excellentes qui existent si on
fait une grande quantité
non seulement le calme se renforcent
très rapidement mais en plus ça se
rapproche des moments où on est stressé
et donc ça permet de l'aider
sensibiliser tous
[Musique]
je vous invite bien sûr avoir d'autres
projets de vie d'autres projets concrets
en ce moment c'est être l'occasion par
exemple de regarder les mots-clés cours
qui sont en ligne d'apprendre quelque
chose qu'on a toujours voulu faire ou
bien c'est peut-être l'occasion de se
dire bon bah voilà ça fait des années et
des années que je me dis bon t'as pas le
temps de faire si t'as pas le temps de
faire ses ratuvou drapeaux espagnols non
c'est pas possible tu voudrais apprendre
l'informatique non c'est pas possible tu
voudras apprendre à programmer non là
c'est possible donc tous les projets qui
sont restés en réserve la champions
devraient peindre depuis des années le
grand ménage le grand rangement
apprendre le latin si les gens qui
aiment ça ou peu importe où apprendre le
macramé ou vraiment y'a pas de mauvaises
apprentissage c'est le moment de le
faire le but c'est transformer un temps
contraint en un temps utile et là vous
ne serez plus dans cette impression de
subir
quelque chose qui renforce les angoisses
et l'impression d'être enfermé plus on
est stressé plus on a tendance à agir de
deux manières soit par la tacc la colère
l'agressivité soit par la fuite et par
la peur et donc comme on est enfermé et
bien dès qu'on a une peur on a ce
sentiment primaire qu'il pousse à
vouloir fuir et si on n'a pas cette
possibilité naturellement ça renforce
des crises d'angoissé et ça renforce des
phobies terre raison de plus pour
travailler énormément sur deux choses la
relaxation et être occupé il ya aussi un
autre repaire à mon avis qui est très
important c'est de garder des rythmes où
on n'est pas fait pour faire ce qu'on
veut on est très très peu doué nous les
êtres humains choisir ce qu'on va faire
une chose après l'autre à faire des
choses bonnes pour l'europe et de la
distraction non franchement en début de
crise où maintenant quand vous regardez
la vidéo
organisez votre planning il faut que
vous ayez au moins huit heures
d'activités comme si vous allez au
travail de toute façon si vous pouvez
travailler
faites-le ce sera excellent pour votre
moral et sinon occuper vos vos huit
heures pour vraiment avoir de moins en
moins de temps pour penser pour que
simplement voilà ce soit un changement
de décor vous n'êtes pas au travail
au travail vous n'avez pas le droit de
sortir donc les a priori mal à vous êtes
chez vous n'a pas l'aura de sortir mais
ça peut devenir un temps utile un ton
constructif en tout cas mais c'est son
stress et puis aussi être vraiment avoir
beaucoup d'activités très occupée c'est
vraiment une excellente chose
la première chose la plus simple à faire
quand on est stressé c'est de ne pas
s'attaquer aux causes le pas forcément
essayer de comprendre c'est de
s'attaquer directement aux strass la
relaxation permet de faire ça et parmi
les outils de relaxation l1 qui a
évidemment ma faveur c'est l'hypnose les
blues ou met dans un état de deux très
grande détente dans le corps dans la
tête c'est idéal par exemple pour
s'endormir mais ceux-ci idéal pour
apprendre à être calme et il nous a ce
petit quelque chose en plus par rapport
à la méditation par rapport aux autres
techniques de relaxation
c'est qu'elle permet de travailler sur
soi avec le figaro par exemple on a fait
une séance d'hypnose pour mettre à
distance les infos qu'ils sont
inquiétantes les souvenirs qui sont
douloureux
on a travaillé également sur le fait de
pouvoir s'endormir rapidement le soir on
a travaillé sur la relaxation breil sur
plein de thèmes très très intéressant et
je vous invite juste selon claire vous
avez le temps je vous avais juste après
cette vidéo a essayé une de ces séances
d'hypnose vous notez votre stress de 0 à
100 au départ de kiel approche peut-être
qui frôlera les 90% je ne sais pas et
vous verrez le résultat ensuite vous
n'aurez fait aucun effort il nous aura
lâché un niveau inconscient et vous
sentirez bien mieux et ça il faut le
répéter dire tous les bons conseils
qu'on a pu donner dans cette vidéo
l'importance les structures et de bien
les faire tous les jours on est un petit
peu en prison
bon bah quand on est en prison on a
vraiment besoin d'avoir une hygiène de
vie et de s'y tenir
c'est ce qui permet de ne pas devenir
dingue
[Musique]